ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BACKER PORCHES BRADFORD
CABALLERO COURTS HAVING DALLY
DODD THE RUSSELL EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG WEST
SO HER TADO. JONES KAMLAGER
LAYERED LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN. NEWMAN NIELSEN
OTOBO PAN PORTANTINO ROCK RUBIO
SKINNER STERN. AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE WE WIENER WILK. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LET
HIM PRODUCE AFTERNOON BY SENATOR
SKINNER AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR OCHO ABOVE
SENATORS I HAVE TO DO THE PRAYER. GRACIOUS AND LOVING CREATOR.
AS WE RECOIL FROM THE MANY ACTS
OF VIOLENCE. PERPETRATED EACH
DAY. GIVE US RENEWED HOPE. IN
OUR ABILITY TO MEND THE
BROKENNESS OF OUR WORLD. BECAUSE
IN THE WORDS OF DENISE LEVERTOV
SPOON BEGINNERS. WE HAVE ONLY
BEGUN TO LOVE YEARS WE'VE ONLY
BEGUN TO IMAGINE THE FULLNESS OF
LIFE HOW COULD RETIRE OF HOPE SO
MUCH IS IN BY. HOW CAN DESIRE
FAIL WE HAVE ONLY BEGUN TO
IMAGINE JUSTICE AND MERCY ONLY
BEGAN TO ENVISION HOW IT MIGHT.
BE TO LIVE AS SIBLINGS WITH EACH
OTHER NOT AS OPPRESSORS. THERE
IS TOO MUCH BROKEN THAT MUST BE
AMENDED TO MUCH HURT WE HAVE
DONE TO EACH OTHER THAT CAN NOT
YET BE FORGIVEN. WE'VE ONLY
BEGUN TO KNOW THE POWER THAT IS
IN S IF WE SHOULD JOIN OUR
SOLITUDES IN THE COMMUNION OF
STRUGGLE. SO MUCH IS UNFOLDING
THAT MUST COMPLETE ITS GESTURE
SO MUCH IS IN BIRD. ARMEN ARMEN. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDG OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED. IT IS LAW. STRONG I'D
LIKE TO ASK OUR MEMBERS AND OUR
VISITORS- TO PLEASE STAY
STANDING WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR THE
VICTIMS OF THE HORRIFIC GUN
VIOLENCE IN ORANGE COUNTY AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THIS WEEKEND.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO PROVISIONS OF THE
FLORIDA WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH YOU SENATOR JONES PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I HAVE TWO
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY THAT I
WOULD LOVE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
THIS AFTERNOON FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO HONOR BRISTOL TAYLOR
DIXON FOR HER COMMITMENT TO
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE FOR
EXAMPLE YOUR RECORD OF PEER
LEADERSHIP AND HER OUTSTANDING
DISPLAY OF SCHOOL COMMUNITY
SPIRIT. AS A FIFTH GRADER W. D.
HALL ELEMENTARY BRISTOL HAS
RECENTLY BEEN PROMOTED TO
COLONEL OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SCHOOL SAFETY PATROLS ALTHOUGH
ONLY TWELVE YEARS OLD SHE HAS
AMBITIONS TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL IS ONE OF THE TOP
STUDENTS IN HER CLASS ATTEND
COLLEGE TO BECOME A TEACHER AND
PARTICIPATE IN OLYMPIC
WEIGHTLIFTING I CAME IN BRISTOL
FOR HER USING HER TALENTS AND
RESOURCES TO SERVE OTHERS
CONGRADULATIONS BRISTOL AND I
WISH YOU THE BEST YEAR
SCHOLASTIC FUTURE AND LEADERSHIP
TO KEEP UP THE GREAT WORK.
RELATIONS BRISTOL AND WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO INTRODUCE
KINGSTON CRUISE CHAU VICE WHO'S
ALSO UP IN THE GALLERY. KINGSTON
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND EXEMPLARY
COMMITMENT EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE AMONG HIS FIFTH GRADE
PEERS AT ELEVEN YEARS OLD
KINGSTON IS THE KERNEL OF THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY SAFETY PATROLS
AND STUDENT COUNCIL PRESIDENT AT
W. D. ALL ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
EVEN FILLS BOTH ROLES WITHIN
THIRTY HAS M. AND A GREAT SENSE
OF RESPONSIBILITY KANSEN IS
HIGHLY RESPECTED BY BOTH HIS
TEACHERS AND CLASSMATES FOR
FULFILLING HIS ACADEMIC DUTIES
AND HIS RESPONSIBILITIES AS A
STUDENT CITIZEN WITH PRIDE AND
MATURITY. INSPIRES OTHERS
THROUGH HIS ACTIONS AND
DEDICATION AMBITION TO BE A
GREAT LEADER AND ROLE MODEL FOR
HIS FELLOW STUDENTS
CONGRADULATIONS KINGSTON AND I
WISH YOU THE BEST IN YOUR
SCHOLASTIC FEATURE FUTURE AND
LEADERSHIP EFFORTS. KEEP UP THE
GREAT WORK CONGRADULATIONS
KINGSTON WILL COME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE SENATOR
JONES MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIS. WE CAN WAIT TILL EVERYONE
GETS SETTLED. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK
OF MAY NINETEENTH NINE THREE
TWELVE TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE FOLLOWING BILL WITH FOUR
MINUTES WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN SB NINE SEVENTY ONE
SENATOR NEWMAN. OUR MEMBERS
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SENATOR BASS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF STEPHEN PANELLI TO THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD.
MISTER PANELLI HAS BEEN A CHIEF
PLUMBING INSPECTOR AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF BUILDING
INSPECTION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINE HE WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
TWENTIETH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BATES MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FORTUS BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ THE- DALLINGTON I DODD. I
DURAZO. I EGGMAN. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE HERTZBERG I
REQUEST SO HI FOR TIDAL I JONES
I KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ
FIVE MIN AYE NEWMAN. NIELSEN I A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO HI
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE ON BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. WIENER AYE WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN I ATKINS BAKER.
FORTUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ
GROWTH. NEWMAN I'M BURKE WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI. BUYS THIRTY NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF JOSE HERNANDEZ FOR THE
APPOINTMENT TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGENTS
REGENT HERNANDEZ IS A FORMER
NATIONAL AERONAUTICS AND SPACE
ADMINISTRATION ASTRONAUT. IN THE
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF TEAR ON THE NOT
ENGINEERING HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE- ON MAY FOURTH ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING MEN AND I'M GONNA ASK
THOSE THAT ARE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS TO TAKE THEM OFF
BEFORE PLEASE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS. EIGHT I
BAKER FORTUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTEZ THREE. DOLLY DODD. I
DURACELL I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. GROSS. HERTZBERG AYE
WESSEL AYE HURTADO AYE JONES.
KAMLAGER HI THERE I LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO
MAN I NEWMAN. NIELSEN I A SHOW
ABOUT. PAN I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AYE
NUMBER WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK. HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS BAKER
LARGESSE RADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE DALLY. GONZALEZ GROSS I
. JONES NEWMAN A CHOI BOGUE.
AMBERG IS TWENTY SEVEN IT'S NOSE
ONE THAT THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR REQUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MATTER
PRESIDENT IF YOU WOULD NOT MIND
CLEAN PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIXTEEN ACTIVE FIVE THANK YOU
SENATOR MARK MCGWIRE THE DESK
WILL NOTE RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW MOVING TO SENATE THIRD
READING AND WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH. FILE ITEM. SEVENTY NINE.
WHICH IS SENATOR WIENER ARE YOU
READY SENATOR WIENER. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR
WIENER RELATIVE TO NATIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT BECAUSE
THEIR RIGHTS TO PRESENT S. R.
EIGHTY SIX- ON MY OWN BEHALF
AND- OF THE SENATOR FROM
STOCKTON WE HOPE CORPUSCLE TAPE
US SENTIMENTAL HEALTH CAUCUS.
SORRY SIX RECOGNIZES MAY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS NATIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA- IN 201911% OF
AMERICAN ADULTS REPORTED
SYMPTOMS OF THINGS AN ANXIETY OR
DEPRESSIVE DISORDER. NOW OF
COURSE AS A RESULT OF COVER
NINETEEN AND THE MANY CHALLENGES
THAT ACCOMPANY THE PANDEMIC THE
RATE HAS JUMPED 2401% OVER HALF
OF ADULTS IN THE U. S. MORE-
WITH A MENTAL. HEALTH CONDITION
DO NOT RECEIVE TREATMENT. AND
THE PERCENTAGE OF ADULTS TO
REPORT AN UNMET NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT HAS INCREASED
EVERY YEAR SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN.
THESE UNADDRESSED MENTAL HEALTH-
PROBLEMS WORSEN OTHER CRISES
LIKE HOMELESSNESS POVERTY
EMPLOYMENT- SAFETY- AND ECONOMIC
ARE DEEPLY IMPACTED IN DIFFERENT
WAYS BY THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS- AND WE NEED MORE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CARE-
COLLEAGUES WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THE RAPIDLY EVOLVING MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS THAT GRIPS OUR
NATION. AND OUR STATE WE MUST
PRIORITIZE INCREASING ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND WORK
TO CHANGE THE STIGMA REGARDING
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. ON YOUR
DESK YOU WILL SEE A LIME GREEN
RIBBON WHICH ARE WARNED TO BRING
AWARENESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES HELD TO MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO WEAR YOUR RIBBON TODAY-
IN HONOR OF NATIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CENTER WIENER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY I'M
SORRY CENTER PANTS SO SORRY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
SATURDAY TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SR EIGHTY SIX AND I
THINK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WE GET FROM TO
STOCKTON FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
AND MENTAL HEALTH. I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN OUR YOUTH ACTUALLY
BEGAN BEFORE COATED. IN FACT THE
- IN SURVEYS OF THE ICC'S YOUTH
RISK BEHAVIOR SURVEILLANCE
SURVEY SHOWED THAT. ONE IN THREE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS HAD
EXPERIENCED A PERSISTENT
FEELINGS OF SADNESS. OR
HOPELESSNESS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT'S THE FOR KOBE. WHICH WAS A
40% INCREASE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE. AND THE TWENTY
NINETEEN AGAIN BEFORE COVERED
ONE AND SIX RECORDED REPORTED
MAKING A SUICIDE PLAN. SO
CLEARLY ARE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
ARE NOT JUST RESULT OF CODED
BUT- HAD BEEN A LONG ONGOING
ISSUE SINCE BEFORE THEN. I KNOW
HERE IN THIS VERY CHAMBER WE
HAVE. DEBATED AND MOVE FORWARD
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THIS
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. IS EVEN
BEFORE THAT AND SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
WHO HAVE DONE THAT. WE HAVE AN
ONGOING CRISIS AND- WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THIS. AND SO
I STRICTLY ASPEN AYE VOTE ON SR
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER PAN MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN MEMBER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS BATES.
BAKER PORCHES BRADFORD CABALLERO
CARTAXI ALLEN I DON. I TO
RUSSELL I EGGMAN. I LAZER AYE
GONZALEZ GROVE. HERTZBERG AYE
WESSEL AYE RETARDER AYE JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I LEYVA I
LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ AYE
MIN AYE NEWMAN NIELSEN I WOULD
SHOW UP BOTH HI PAM. I
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE ON BURKE
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE
WILK AYE THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS. EIGHT I BAKER
FORTUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTELLI GONZALEZ. GROVE I
MCGUIRE I NEWMAN I'M BURKE. IS
THIRTY ONE NEW DOES ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO.
SENATOR PAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO A API
DAY AGAINST BULLYING AND HATE.
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS SISTER THANK
YOU THE SHARE THE ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. PLEASE TO PRESENT S. C.
ARE AT NINETY FOUR PROCLAIMS MAY
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS
THE API DAY AGAINST BULLYING AND
HATE. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR OLD VINCENT
CHEN WAS MURDERED AT THE HANDS
OF TWO CAUCASIAN MEN WHO BEAT
HIM TO DEATH IN MICHIGAN JUST
EIGHT DAYS BEFORE HIS WEDDING.
THE TWO MEN WHO KILLED TEN WERE
AUTO WORKERS AND MISTAKENLY
THOUGHT HE WAS TRYING JAPANESE.
THEY BLAME CHEN FOR THE SUCCESS
OF THE JAPANESE AUTO INDUSTRY.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE STATE
OF MICHIGAN INCARCERATED NEARLY
FOURTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE MOST OF
WHOM WERE PEOPLE OF COLOR
NEITHER OF THE WHITE MURDERS%
EVER SERVE A DAY IN JAIL FOR
THIS CRIME. THIS MISCARRIAGE OF
JUSTICE IGNITED THE ASIAN
AMERICAN ACTIVISM MOVEMENT THAT
CONTINUES TODAY. WE KNOW THAT
THE FIGHT AGAINST RACIAL BIGOTRY
IS FAR FROM OVER S EVIDENCED BY
THE HORRIBLE MASS SHOOTING IN
BUFFALO THIS WEEKEND. ACTED
CHANGES ONE OF THE NATIONAL
NONPROFITS CONTINUING THE
MOVEMENT AGAINST PULLING
DIRECTED AT ASIAN AMERICAN
NATIVE HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY. THE
LEGISLATURE GIANTS ACT CHANGE
ENSURING ONE VISION A WORLD
WHERE ALL USE INCLUDING THE API
COMMUNITY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GROW UP FEELING PROUD AND
SUPPORTED THE DEVELOPMENT THEIR
IDENTITIES AND SHARING THEIR
STORIES. I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
TODAY REMEMBERING THE LIFE AND
STORY OF VINCENT CHEN ON MAY
EIGHTEENTH WHICH SHOULD HAVE
BEEN HIS SIXTY SEVENTH BIRTHDAY
AND TAKING A STAND AGAINST HATE
EVERYWHERE. I STRICTLY ASKED WE
EITHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PAN MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TED TODAY
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. C.
R. NINETY FOUR THAT RECOGNIZES
MAY EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AS A API DAY AGAINST BULLYING
AND HATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I REPRESENT ONE OF
THE LARGEST ASIAN POPULATIONS IN
THE UNITED STATES AND I'VE
TALKED TO SO MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING
AFFECTED BY ALL THE HATE THAT IS
GOING ON IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
OFTEN SPEAK TO STUDENT GROUPS
AND THEY'RE SO PASSIONATE AND
ENGAGED IN THE CONVERSATION.
WITH THEIR PEERS AND OTHERS AND
THEIR COMMUNITY AND THEY TRY TO
EDUCATE AND BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND I THANK HIM FOR
THAT AND THEY'RE TRYING SO HARD
TO PREVENT HATRED AND BIGOTRY.
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
SHOW OUR SUPPORT WE NEED TO
STAND WITH THE AAPI COMMUNITY
AND I AM GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
ALLOWING US TO PUBLICLY SHOW
SUPPORT THE RIGHTS OF ANTI ASIAN
HATE CRIMES THAT WE HAVE SEEN
HAS NO PLACE IN OUR SOCIETY.
LET'S COMMIT TO OURSELVES TO
ENDING HATRED AND BIGOTRY AND
PROTECTING ALL COMMUNITIES IF
YOU WITNESS HATE CRIMES OR
INCIDENTS PLEASE SPEAK UP
PEOPLE'S LIVES DEPEND ON IT. WE
ARE HERE ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
UR COMMUNITIES AND SHOW OUR
SUPPORT WITH THAT I ALSO ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON. S. C. R. NINETY
FOUR THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
PAM WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- I.
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM BALDWIN PARK FOR HER WORDS
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
SPEAK OUT WHEN THEY SEE ACCESS
STATE- SO WE DO HAVE STAND BY
YOUR TRAINING. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE SIMPLY NOT
LETTING GO BY. AND SO AGAIN- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE ON
THIS YEAR NINETY FOUR AND THANK
A PRETTY TESTAMENT. THANK YOU
CENTER AND MEMBER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER FORTUS BRADFORD BY
ADAM WHAT HAS HE DALLY I DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ GROWTH. I HERTZBERG I
REQUEST SO I HER DAUGHTER I
JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA AYE LIMON I MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ AYE MIN. I NEWMAN.
NIELSEN. A TROUBLED AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER I STERN I AM BURKE
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER. I WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BACKER FORTUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO FOR TAXIS GONZALEZ
NEWMAN NIELSEN I ON BURKE ICE
THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS REMOVING
THE FILE ITEM FORTY CENTER PAN
AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE OF
THREE BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO
CYSTIC FIBROSIS AWARENESS MONTH
CENTER PAM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SANDERS TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT S. YOUR WINDOWS THREE
AN ACT THAT WOULD COMMEMORATE
MAY TWENTY SECOND. MAY TWENTY
TWENTY SORRY A CYSTIC FIBROSIS
AWARENESS MONTH IS THE WHOLE
MONTH. CYSTIC FIBROSIS IS A
CHRONIC AND PROGRESSIVE SYSTEMIC
DISEASE AND IT'S THE MOST COMMON
FATAL GENETIC DISEASE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND ONE FOR WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO KNOWN
CURE. THEIR APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND CHILDREN ADULTS WHO
HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH THE
DISEASE AND THOUSANDS MORE ARE
DIAGNOSED EVERY YEAR. LIFE
SCIENCES COMPANIES IN NEW
TECHNOLOGIES DISCOVER NEW
ADVANCES IN THERAPIES AND
RESEARCH THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
DISCOVER A CURE FOR THIS
DISEASE. MEDICATION CALIFORNIA'S
INCREASED INVESTMENTS IN NEWBORN
SCREENING TO DETECT THE RARE
CYSTIC FIBROSIS GENE
TRANSMEMBRANE CONDUCTANCE
REGULATOR. DESPITE THESE
ADVANCES THERE'S STILL MORE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. I WANT TO
THANK THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS
RESEARCH INSTITUTE FOR THEIR
YEARS OF WORK TO PROVIDE
RESEARCH EDUCATION OUTREACH TO
FAMILIES LISTENING. LIVING WITH
CYSTIC FIBROSIS AND I WANT TO
ALSO RECOGNIZE THIS FAMILIES FOR
THEIR ADVOCACY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY.
PHYSICAL ADDRESSES CARE. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RAISING AWARENESS OF
THE DISEASE SO THAT WE CAN
INCREASE THE SUPPORT A HEALTH
ACCESS FOR FAMILIES AFFECTED ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS YEAR
ONEOF THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER PAM MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. MEMBERS THIS
IS A QUALIFIED FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THING
IN HER NONE I WAS THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT SENATOR
SKINNER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER RELATIVE TO
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE AWARENESS MONTH SANDERS
CAN- THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT YES
YOUR WINDOWS SEVEN WHICH
DESIGNATES MAY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AS CALIFORNIA'S MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
AWARENESS MONTH. ALMOST EIGHTY
PERCENT. OF OUR INDIGENOUS
POPULATION IN THE US. WILL
EXPERIENCE SOME FORM OF PHYSICAL
ABUSE IN THEIR LIFETIME. IN OVER
ONE HALF OF THEM A SEXUAL
ASSAULT. ON SOME RESERVATIONS
INDIGENOUS WOMEN ARE MURDERED AT
TEN TIMES THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE WERE
FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED CASES OF
MURDERED AND MISSING INDIGENOUS
WOMEN AND GIRLS REPORTED TO THE
NATIONAL CRIME CENTER. LAST
YEAR. IN RESPONSE TO THIS AND
DUE TO ADVOCACY BY TRIBES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR'S TABLETS THE
MISSING AND MURDERED UNIT WITHIN
THE BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS
OFFICE OF JUSTICE SERVICES. THAT
WILL ADD WEIGHT IN NEW ENERGY TO
THE INVESTIGATION AND RESOLVING
OF THESE CASES. THE FBI U. S.
ATTORNEY'S TRIBAL POLICE AND THE
BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS. NEED
TO BETTER COORDINATE TO LOCATE
INDIGENOUS INDIVIDUALS. AND WE
NEED TO BE PERSISTENT AND
CONSISTENT IN INCREASING
AWARENESS IN TAKING MORE
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES AND
RESOLVING THESE CASES SO LOVED
ONES CAN HAVE CLOSURE. YES YOUR
ONE OR SEVEN IS A CALL TO ACTION
. SO THAT THESE MISSING
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE ARE NO LONGER
INVISIBLE WITHIN OUR SOCIETY.
FIVE TWO WEEKS AGO I ATTENDED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RON NOTICES
EVENT THAT BROUGHT ATTENTION TO
THIS ISSUE AND HAD MANY OUR
TRIBAL FOLKS PRESENT. BUT IT
ALSO WAS FOLLOWED BY A PLAY
WRITTEN BY A YOUNG CALIFORNIA
INDIGENOUS WOMAN WHO WROTE THE
PLAY WHEN SHE WAS SIXTEEN. AND
IT BASICALLY TELLS THE STORY OF
A GIRL WHO WAS AT HER MISSING
AND FOR WHOM THE- AUTHORITIES
WOULD NOT DEAL JUST KEPT DEALING
WITH AS A RUN AWAY. UNTIL MONTHS
LATER WHEN THEY FOUND HER BODY
BUT IT WAS ERY VERY MOVING AND
THIS YOUNG WOMAN HAS RECEIVED
MANY AWARDS FOR IT. BUT WHY SHE
NEEDED TO HAVE AS HER FIRST WORK
THAT WAY BE SOMETHING AROUND A
TRAGEDY OF THIS. PROPORTION I
THINK ALL IS SOMETHING ALL OF US
HAVE TO JOIN TOGETHER TO TRY TO
STOP AND PREVENT IN WITHOUT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THE TIME. THE
HIGHEST SUICIDE RATE. FOUR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR IS- IS NATIVE
AMERICAN AND THEY THE SUICIDE
RATE IS HIGHEST IN THAT IN THAT
CATEGORY FROM FROM EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD-AND THE
MANY OF THOSE ARE. TAKING A LIFE
SO I JUST WANT TO STAND. WITH
SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS ELEVEN
COUNTIES IN A LOT OF SMALLER-
DRIVE WE GET WE OFTEN THINK OF.
THE LARGER ONES THAT HAVE-
GAMING BUT THERE'S MANY MANY
MANY. A SMALLER RESERVATIONS AND
TRIBES THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT
THAT TIME I JUST WANNA
RECOGNIZES PEOPLE FOR THE
TOUGHEST- LIFESTYLES IT THERE OR
PUT IN IN. SUPPORT RESOLUTION-
S. R. ONE OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DALITS UNDER
NIELSEN. MR PRESIDENT LADIES ON
THE SENATE. THESE INDIGENOUS
AMERICANS ARE THE TRUE AMERICANS
ONES THAT WE MOST ASSUREDLY
SHOULD RECOGNIZE. AND REMEMBER.
I TO HAVE A GREAT EMPATHY FOR
THE AMERICAN INDIANS
REPRESENTING A AGAIN A LOT OF
THE TRIBAL. MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
MY CAREER. AND I THINK ABOUT THE
GREAT PLAINS. AND ALL OF THE-
DIGITIZATION THE INTO FOSTER
LIFE IN MANY WAYS. BUT THEIR
LIVES THEIR BODIES LAY A- IN
THAT SOIL. THE ISSUE IS WHEN
THERE IS A LOST LOVED ONE. FOR
THE FAMILY TO AT LEAST KNOW.
WHERE THEY ARE. I DON'T KNOW IF
IT ACHIEVES CLOSURE. I'VE FOUND
THAT OVER THE DECADES. CLOSURE
NEVER REALLY HAPPENS. BECAUSE
THE ISSUE THE LOVED ONE AND
THEIR FEELINGS FOR THAT LOVE
WILL NEVER GO AWAY. THERE ARE
REMINDED AND THEIR HEARTS ACHE
EVERY BIRTHDAY. EVERY HOLIDAY
EVERY PASSING MOMENT WHEN
SOMETHING SPARKS NEVER MIND THAT
THEY SEE THAT REMINDS THEM. OF
THAT LOST LOVED ONES. THIS IS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT. IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT FOR JUSTICE. FOUR
IF WE FIND THAT INDIVIDUAL.
THERE MAY BE OPPORTUNITIES IF
IT'S A CRIME. TO SEE JUSTICE
DONE. THERE ARE MANY REASONS
THAT IS WE VOTE FOR THIS. THANK
OF THOSE HEARTBROKEN FAMILY
MEMBERS AND YOU ARE BY YOUR AYE
VOTE REMEMBERING THEM. AN EASING
THE PAIN IN THEIR HEARTS I
REGIONAL APPROACH THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR CHAU BOOK. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF STR ONE OF SEVEN. I'M ALSO
PROBABLY WEARING THESE EARRINGS
THEY WERE ACTUALLY MADE BY THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF CHAIRMEN
RAMIREZ'S- FROM THE SAN MANUEL
BAND I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET WITH THESE YOUNG LADIES.
ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO IN WHICH
THEY SHARE THEIR PASSION AND
THEIR NEW ADVOCACY THEIR VOICE
IN ADVOCACY FOR THE MISSING
INDIGENOUS WOMEN THESE FIFTEEN
IS SIX YEAR OLD GIRLS GIVEN
AMAZING PRESENTATION- ON BEHALF
OF THESE. WOMEN AND- I STAND IN
CELEBRATE SOLIDARITY WITH THEM
TODAY. I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT
SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY THREE
WHICH HAS A STRONG NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY ACCORDING TO
RECENT SAYS CENSUS DATA THE
INLAND EMPIRE AREA IS HOME TO
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. IT IS SO
DISHEARTENING TO ME THAT THESE
VALUED MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE TO
DISPROPORTIONATE RISK OF
EXPERIENCING VIOLENCE MURDER OR
GOING MISSING. AND MAKE UP A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
MISSING AND MURDERED CASES.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
THE MURDER RATE IS TEN TIMES
HIGHER FOR WOMEN LIVING ON
RESERVATIONS. THEN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE AND THIRD LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH FOR NATIVE WOMEN. MORE
THAN FOUR IN FIVE NATIVE
AMERICAN AND ALASKA NATIVE MEN
WHICH TOTALS TO MORE THAN ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION HAVE
EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE IN THEIR
LIFETIME. THESE STATISTICS ARE
SHOCKING AND UNACCEPTABLE.
EVERYONE DESERVES TO FEEL SAFE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WE MUST
DO MORE TO SUPPORT OUR
INDIGENOUS BROTHERS AND SISTERS
I RISE TODAY TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THESE
COMMUNITIES AND URGENT AYE VOTE
ON S. C. R. ONE OF SEVEN. THANK
YOU SENATOR CHAU BOOK SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND TODAY
I ALSO STAND AND RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. ONE OH
SEVEN. I ALSO ATTENDED A PRESS
CONFERENCE HIGHLIGHTING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT. ARE MANY
TIMES IN OUR SOCIETY WILL FOLLOW
ONE CASE OF ONE MISSING PERSON
FOR MINE SAID I BELIEVE
RIGHTFULLY SOUL EVERY LIFE
MATTERS. BUT AS ALREADY STATED
WOMEN INDIGENOUS WOMEN ARE TEN
TIMES. OF MOST LIKE MORE LIKELY
TO BE MURDERED AND YET WE DON'T
HEAR ABOUT THEM EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND STILL TO ME THIS IS A CALL
TO ACTION TO ENCOURAGE. OUR
MEDIA OUTLETS OUT THERE TO PUT A
SPOTLIGHT ON THIS IS A TRAVESTY
SO MANY WOMEN GO MISSING AND
MURDERED AND WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT
THEM SO AGAIN I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND SOLIDARITY. HI AND
THIS ARE MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AWARENESS
MONTH TO REALLY ENCOURAGE ALL OF
US TO PAY MORE ATTENTION TO
THESE WOMEN. AND THEIR IMPORTANT
TO US IN OUR SOCIETY SO WITHOUT
AYE ORIGIN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BY. M. YES THANK YOU I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY EXCUSE ME MEMBERS THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
EASIER UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED NEXT
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM TWENTY
SIX SENATOR NIELSEN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR NIELSEN AN ACT RELATING
TO PUPIL INSTRUCTION. CENTER
NIELSEN. BETTER PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THIS IS
AN APPROPRIATE WEEK FROM THE
PRESENTATION OF THIS BILL ON THE
FLOOR. THIS BILL WILL. ALLOW IN
OUR K. TWELVE NOT AS A MANDATE.
BUT IF YOU WILL A RECOMMENDATION
. THE API HISTORY AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THEIR TO. BE
TAUGHT IN OUR SCHOOLS. THERE ARE
OTHER THERE'S NOTHING
ETHNICITIES WHO ARE RIGHTLY SO
RECOGNIZED IN.A BILL THAT
PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO GO
SOMEWHAT IN THAT DIRECTION. BUT
I THINK THAT THIS IS MORE
DEFINITIVE. AND MORE ENCOURAGING
. THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ASSOCIATION. I
DON'T OFTEN MENTION THE SPONSORS
BUT THIS ONE IS IMPORTANT. ABOUT
TWENTY ONE YEARS AGO SIX OF A
SET DOWN IN A SMALL OFFICE AND
CONCEIVED THE IDEA OF AN ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER ORGANIZATION.
THAT WOULD BE MORE UNIVERSAL.
AND THIS PURPOSE WOULD BE TO
EMPOWER ENHANCE TO BE AN
ASSISTANT. THE DEVELOPMENT IN
OUR API COMMUNITY. ONE OF THE
DECISIONS WE MADE THEN IN THAT
MEETING IT WOULD BE BROUGHT. AND
OUR INTERNSHIP OR SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM WOULD BE FOR ASIAN YOUTH
AND MANY OF YOU HAVE HAD A
PROPER TURF INTERNS IN YOUR
OFFICES. THE TREMENDOUS
SUCCESSFUL YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN.
WE ALSO DECIDED THAT WOULD BE
CALLED ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN. PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ASSOCIATION. SO WE REALIZED THAT
THESE. WE'RE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE PROMINENT AND CONTRIBUTING
TO. AMERICA WE ALSO. ENSURED
THAT WE WOULD NOT BE EXCLUSIVE
BUT RATHER INCLUSIVE. INVOLVING
ALL ETHNICITIES IN OUR
ACTIVITIES. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ANOTHER BIG ONE DOWN AT THE END
RANCH. OF THE BACK OF BILL THIS
WEDNESDAY. IT ENCOURAGES OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COURAGE AND
VISION OPERATIVE WORD. WE'RE
WARY OF MANDATES. BUT I THINK
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY. ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA
. THE MOST DISTRICTS WILL
COOPERATE. OVER THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS WE'VE HAD A
PARTICULAR ADVANCEMENT. THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER.
OPERATIVE WORD ISLANDER
SOUTHEAST ASIANS COME TO AMERICA
. TO MAKE THEIR WAY. AND NOT BE
DEPENDENT ON THIS COUNTRY BUT TO
BE CONTRIBUTORS THE COUNTRY. AND
THEY ARE AMAZING CONTRIBUTORS.
THEY DIDN'T USED TO BE IN THIS
INSTITUTION. MANY ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATORS. NOW THERE
ARE MANY. THE HEAD CLOSURE. THE
KNOWING MANY OF THEM. HOW
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS. OUR
SUPPORTIVE FOR SURE. PMR.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA. DID HE-
FRIENDS AND BIG SUPPORTERS. OF
OUR EFFORTS. THIS ORGANIZATION
NO THIS BILL SPONSORED BY A POP
IN. HAS SIXTY FOUR ORGANIZATIONS
ENDORSING. AND OVER TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED LETTERS THAT COME INTO
OUR OFFICES. IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THAT'S A STRONG
RECOGNITION THERE ARE FEW BILLS
. THAT GARNER THAT KIND OF
ATTENTION. THAT KIND OF SUPPORT. I NEVER SPEAK TO. AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS THE TRUE
FOUNDER. MISTER CCM. VERILY A
BROTHER TO ME. ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL FRANCHISEES OF
MCDONALD'S IN AMERICA. BUT HE IS
DEVOTED TO. THE GOOD PART OF HIS
LIFE. TO HELPING. ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS. HIS WIFE
REGINA. ARE GOING TO BE
DEDICATING THEIR BEAUTIFUL RANCH
. FOR THE PURPOSE AT THE
HEADQUARTERS. FOR API ENDEAVORS
THAT EMPOWER POWERMAN. THIS IS
AND THEN A PORTENT IS A CLOSE.
TO ALLOW OUR STUDENTS. MANY OF
WHOM DON'T HAVE MUCH CONTACT
WITH ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
THE VALUE IN THE PARTICIPATION.
ON MY LAPEL TODAY I'M WEARING
SOMETHING THAT HARD TO BE
DISCERNED EVEN THREE TINY. BUT
IT IS A REPLICA OF THE GOLDEN
SPIKE. THE GOLDEN SPIKE WAS
DRIVEN. TO THE RAILROAD TIES TO
. PROMONTORY POINT UTAH
COMPLETING THE TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD. THE CHINESE
CONTRIBUTED MIGHTILY THE MOST
DIFFICULT PART. THAT WONDERFUL
COLOSSAL HISTORIC INFASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT IN AMERICA. THEY
BROUGHT THAT RAILROAD. OVER THE
SIERRAS. AND I GET CHILLS WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THE THINGS THAT THEY
DID. I'VE READ BOOKS ABOUT THEIR
HISTORY. THE RISKS THEY TOOK. NO
LIVES WERE LOST. SO THAT WE
COULD UNITE THE EAST COAST. ON
THE WEST COAST. AND ALL OF
AMERICA. IT WOULD BE WELL THAT
OUR STUDENTS AND K. TWELVE. ARE
AWARE OF THIS WONDERFUL
CONTRIBUTION. I ASKED MY
COLLEAGUES FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
. THERE IS. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER FORGES BRADFORD
CABALLERO QUARTET THE- VALLEY I
DODD AYE THEY'RE AWESOME. EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ GROW AYE
HERTZBERG AYE WESA AYE FURTADO
AYE JONES I KAMLAGER. LAYERED I
LEYVA I LIMÓN. MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MIN. NEWMAN NIELSEN
AYE OR TROUBLE HI PAM.
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER. STERN I'M BURKE WHY
CASTING I WIENER AYE WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BACKER BORJAS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE THEY'RE AWESOME.
GONZALEZ KAMLAGER LIMÓN MANY
NEWMAN PAM SKINNER STERN- BURKE
I TWENTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR PAN AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR PAM AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY CENTER PAN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SANDERS- I'M PLEASE PRESENT SB
NINE NINETY SEVEN WHICH IS A
BILL THEY'LL AMPLIFY STUDENT
VOICES IN STUDENT AND SCHOOL
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS. SB NINE NINE
SEVEN STRENGTHENS TO
PARTICIPATION IN CONVERSATIONS
REGARDING LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN SUPERVISE
ELEAZAR TWO OPTIONS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. THE FIRST ADDS
TO STUDENT NUMBERS TO ANY PARENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT REVIEWS
THE L. CATS. THE SECOND OPTION
ALLOWS THE CREATION OF AN ENTIRE
STUDENT VIæT COMMITTEE TO REVIEW
THE- CAP. THE- CAP IS A POWERFUL
PLANNING TOOL THAT HELPS
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION OUTLINED GOALS ACTION
SERVICES AND EXPENDITURES.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES H. ELLIE
EIGHT HAVE A PARENT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE PROVIDES INPUT ON THE
EL CAP HOWEVER STUDENT BUT
ASSEMBLY SOLICITED THROUGH MEANS
OF GENERAL. POPULATION SUCH AS
SURVEYS AND FORMS. IN THE WAKE
OF THE ON GOING PANDEMIC THE
MOST PRESSING EDUCATIONAL%
CHALLENGES SUCH AS LEARNING LOS
LAPSES AND MOTIVATION CHRONIC
ABSENTEES ISM MENTAL HEALTH
CRISES AND MORE ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO
ADDRESS. AND WITH THE LACK OF
STUDENT REPRESENTATION ON MOST
EL CAP ADVISORY COMMITTEES
APPELLEE DATA FIVE SECONDLY DONE
A FINE ADDRESS THE MOST PRESSING
CHALLENGES OUR STUDENTS FACE. IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT OUR
LOCAL IT CAN AGENCIES INVOLVED
STUDENTS DIRECTLY IN THE OIL CAP
PROCESS IN ORDER TO ADAPT
PRIORITIES AND ENSURE THE BUDGET
REFLECT IMMEDIATE CONCERNS OF
STUDENTS. THIS BILL KNOWLEDGES
THERE'S NO SIMPLE SUBSTITUTE FOR
STUDENT VOICES IN EDUCATION
POLICY OKAY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS A VOICE AT THE TABLE.
SB NINE NINE SEVEN AND JOIN IN
THE END OF THE SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
AND THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
GENERATION UP THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER ASSOCIATION
HAS SUPPORT FROM CHILDREN DOWN
PUBLIC ADVOCATES THERE'S NO
FORMAL REGISTERED OPPOSITION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. C. AND HEARING NONE
HIS TWO. NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING THE FILE ITEM TO
NINE ALSO SENATOR PAN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY BY SENATOR
PAM AN ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES CENTER PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS I'M
ALSO PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THE NEW AND UPCOMING
EVENTS CENTER IN SACRAMENTO
KNOWN AS CAP RADIO LIFE QUALIFY
FOR A LONG TERM. MEDICAL LICENSE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL. FOR THE PAST
FORTY YEARS CAP RADIOS THE LIVER
CRITICAL NEWS AN EXPANDED OUR
WORLD THROUGH STORIES ON ART AND
LAST YEAR JUST LEGISLATURE.
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
EXCESSIVELY TO ARTS INVEST IN
THE CAP RADIO LIFE. THIS NEW
VENUE WOULD OFFER INCLUSIVE
ENGAGING ACCESSIBLE EVENT
EXPERIENCES FOR LOW TO NO COST
HOWEVER CAP RADIO DOES NOT FALL.
WITHIN ONE OF THE A. B. C.'S
ALCOHOL LICENSE TYPES AND
THEREFORE BE UNABLE TO DEPEND ON
THIS CRITICAL REVENUE STREAM.
THEREFORE SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SPECIFIED THIRTY NONPROFIT RADIO
BROADCASTING COMPANY WILL BE
ADDED TO THE MENU OPTIONS THIS
BILL AS WE SEE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ESPECIALLY AFTER I'VE
IT. THANK YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN THIS TOO IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION AS
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE HIGHS THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WE
ARE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE SENATOR KAMLAGER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR KAMLAGER AND AFTER
RELATING TO JUVENILES. SENATE
HOME LONGER GOOD MORNING MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
SEEKS TO PROTECT AND KEEP MORE
FAMILIES TOGETHER BY REDEFINING
NEGLECTED DEPENDENCY COURT THE
CURRENT DEFINITION OF NEGLECT IN
JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURT
HEARINGS IS OVERLY BROAD
ALLOWING PETITIONS FOR REMOVAL
TO BE INITIATED BY SOCIAL
WORKERS FOR RELATIVELY MINOR AND
SOMETIMES TEMPORARY
CIRCUMSTANCES RELATING TO
POVERTY. THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL PROTECTION FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES VULNERABLE
TO SEPARATION BASED ON FACTORS
SUCH AS POVERTY HOMELESSNESS AND
A LACK OF ACCESS TO CERTAIN
RESOURCES THESE FACTORS
ESPECIALLY FOR HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS SHOULD
NOT BE FURTHER ADJUDICATED BY
OUR COURT SEPARATING FAMILIES
FOR UNREASONABLE AND ARBITRARY
REASONS CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS
ALREADY EXIST FOR LACK OF
EMERGENCY SHELTER FAILURE OF
PARENTS TO SEEK COURT ORDERS FOR
CUSTODY OF THE CHILD. AND EVEN
ADEQUATE MEDICAL TREATMENT BASED
ON RELIGIOUS OR SPIRITUAL
CONSIDERATIONS. THE CIVIC
EXCEPTION SHOULD ALSO BE
INCLUDED TO CONSIDER CONDITIONS
OF POVERTY AND LACK OF RESOURCES
AS A PRESENT REALITY FOR MANY
PARENTS SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE WILL
PROTECT VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND ALLOW SOCIAL WORKERS TO MAKE
MORE INFORMED REPORTING OF
NEGLECT. THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AND IT RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THE USER COM LONGER MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
CENTER NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES ON THE SENATE- I DON'T
HAVE ANY PARTICULAR OBJECTIONS
BUT I AM GOING TO HAVE STATE.
AND THE REASON BEING THIS DOES
UNDERMINE PARENTAL AUTHORITY.
AND I'VE SEEN A LOT MORE OF THAT
. AND THE NEGLECT OF CHILDREN.
THAN ANYBODY AROUND HERE BY
YEARS THE BOARD OF PRISON TERMS
. THERE'S A CONSTANT AND MST
CRIMINALS LIVES. THE BROKEN
HEART. THAT MAY HAVE STARTED IN
THE WOMB. AND THEN DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL AND CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
THAT THEY RESORT. TO COMPENSATE
FOR THAT BROKEN HEART. WE DEAL
WITH THEM IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. YOU BET THERE
ARE A LOT OF IRRESPONSIBLE. BAD
PARENTS. AND WE SHOULD CONDEMN.
BUT HERE. THE BROADNESS OF IT
CONCERNS ME. THAT'S GOING TO
ALLOW SOME ABUSE OF THAT. AND
YET ANOTHER OF THIS LEGISLATURE
IS UNDERMINING. OF PARENTAL
AUTHORITY. AND RESPONSIBILITY I
DO NOT- JIM NOBLE. BUT I WILL
ABSTAIN. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE CENTER
CALM WATER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES I- AGREE THAT THE
DEFINITION IS OVERLY BROAD AND
SO THE ATTEMPT OF THIS BILL IS
TO MORE NARROWLY FOCUSED IT
OBVIOUSLY- AND IT STILL KEEPS IN
CODE WILLFUL OR INTENTIONAL
NEGLECT FAILURE TO TAKE CARE OF
A CHILD TO PROVIDE FOR A CHILD.
BUT CURRENTLY SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
ABLE TO SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM
THEIR FAMILIES AND PLACE THEM IN
FOSTER CARE BECAUSE ON ONE
PARTICULAR DAY THEY MAY HAVE A
BROKEN REFRIGERATOR OR NOT
ENOUGH FOOD AND SO THIS SAYS
LET'S HAVE SOCIAL WORKERS MAKE A
MORE INFORMED DECISION CONNECT
THEM WITH RESOURCES BECAUSE AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE CERTAINLY
DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE PROTECTED. BUT IN
TEMPORARY INSTANCES OF POVERTY
OUT WE'D LIKE FOLKS TO GET
RESOURCES RATHER THAN HAVE
FAMILY SEPARATIONS HAPPEN AND
HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN STAY IN OUR
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER CALM WATER
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BACKER FORTUS
RADFORD CABALLERO- TESTING DALLY
. DODD I TO RUSSELL I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG I WESTERN HI FURTADO.
JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA AYE THE MON. I MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ NO MEN AYE NEWMAN
NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH FIVE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN FIVE NUMBER BY
CASTING AYE WIENER. I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES BACKER. BOARD JEFF
BRADFORD ABOUT CORTES IN DALLY.
GONZALEZ ROVE. RETARDER NEWMAN
NEIL THE TROUBLE I'M- WELL. IS
FOUR KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY SENATOR DODD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT INETY SIX BY SENATOR
DODD AN ACT RELATING TO FIRE
PREVENTION SENATOR DODD. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS- SB
EIGHT NINETY SIX CONTINUES ARE
STEADY AND DETERMINED EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
PROTECTION IN HIGH WILDFIRE
THREAT SEVERITY SELVES THIS BILL
WAS RECOMMENDED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST IN A REPORT
RELEASED LAST AUTUMN ACCORDING
TO THE L. A. O. MAINTAINING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE NOT ONLY HELPS
PROTECT THAT HOME IT ALSO
REDUCES THE RISK. THAT WHILE FAR
WILL SPREAD TO NEIGHBORING HOMES
THEREBY HELPING TO PROTECT
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES SB NINETY SIX
WILL INCREASE THE COLLECTION OF
WILDFIRES ASSESSMENT AND
INSPECTION DATA BY INCENTIVIZING
ANY ONE OF SEVERAL AGENCIES THE
DO ASSESSMENTS TO REPORT THE
INSPECTION DATA TO A CENTRAL
DATABASE THAT CAL FIRE WILL BE
MAINTAINING THIS WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO
BETTER ALLOCATE RESOURCES FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND I
ASKED FOR AND I VTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DOT MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IN THE OBJECTION. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ICE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR PORTANTINO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AND AFTER
RELATING TO THE PAYMENT OF
CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE AND
DECLARED THE URGENCY THERE AT
SIX MEDIALLY. CENTER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU A MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- I RISE TO PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE IT'S ONE OF
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE-
SETTLEMENT BILLS- THE CHAIRS OF
THE COMMITTEE EACH YEAR PROVIDE
PAYMENT AUTHORITY FOR LEGAL
CLAIMS APPROVED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THIS URGENCY MEASURE
APPROPRIATE EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. FUND TO PAY FOR
SETTLEMENTS FOR THE FOLLOWING
AMERICANS FOR PROSPERITY FIRST
CAMEL HARRIS AND CEDAR POINT
NURSERY VERSE HOUSE SEAT AT AL
THESE CLAIMS ARE TIME SENSITIVE
AND BOTH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGREE
THAT PAYMENT IS IN THE STATE'S
BEST INTEREST. THE BILL HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ANY OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS. TO KNOW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. EXCUSE ME FIVE
THREE TWO NINE ZERO ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE SENATOR WIENER
. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ARE PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
NINE TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
WIENER AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. CENTER
WIENER THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
. OUR COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY
TWO- THIS BILL IF IT LOOKS
FAMILIAR IT'S BECAUSE IT'S NOT
SB NINE TWENTY TWO IS AN
EXTENSION OF SUNSET EXTENSION.
OF A BILL I AUTHORED AND TWENTY
NINE AND TWENTY TWENTY- AND THAT
WE PASSED SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT.
WHICH CREATED A STATUTORY SICK
WHAT EXEMPTION. OFFER
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS- THESE- IMPORTANT AND
BADLY NEEDED PROJECTS SUCH AS-
WALKING PATHS OF BIKE LANES-
RAPID BUS LANES OF LIGHT RAIL
LINES. I HEALTHCARE PEOPLE GIVE
PEOPLE AN OPTION. TO GET AROUND
OTHER THAN DRIVING- AND HELPS-
HELP US WITH OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
SB NINE TWENTY TWO AND ITS
PREDECESSOR. ORANGES
TRANSPORTATION BILLS THEY ARE
ALSO CLIMATE BILLS. THE LARGEST
SHARE OF OUR STATE'S EMISSIONS-
AND ALMOST HALF COME FROM OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND
DEPENDENCY ON CARS. WITH GAS
PRICES RISING SHARPLY NOW IS A
GREAT TIME TO MAKE IT EASIER AND
FASTER. TO BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS TO GIVE PEOPLE OPTIONS
IN TERMS OF HELPING GET AROUND.
I'M UNFORTUNATELY OUR EFFORTS TO
GIVE PEOPLE OPTIONS OTHER THAN
DRIVING- HAVE NOT GONE AS
QUICKLY AS WE WANTED- WE ARE
INVESTING MORE IN SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION AND NOW IS THE
TIME TO ACTUALLY GET THOSE
DOLLARS ON THE GROUNDS. ARE
FASTER- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE CENTER NIELSEN.
YOU KNOW BILLS LIKE THIS SERVE.
PROBABLY OKAY. BUT THERE ARE
GETTING LESS OKAY WITH ME ALL
THE TIME. WE GIVE SEQUOYAH
OBJECTIONS FOR THINGS LIKE THIS
OR STADIUMS FOR CITIES. TO HELP
MAKE THE MILLIONS. OR SPORTS
TEAM OWNERS TO MAKE THE MILLIONS
DINNERTIME THE PUBLIC. BUT WHERE
DO WE NEED IT. HOW ABOUT IN THE
FOREST IN THE WILDLANDS OF
CALIFORNIA. WHERE THESE
CATACLYSMIC FIRES- DESTROYING US
. THIS MET THIS VERY DAY.
DELEGATION FROM THE SMALL TOWN
OF PARADISE COMPLETELY DESTROYED
. BY A FIRE. THAT WAS NO SMALL
MAINTENANCE A MEASURE. A RESULT
OF DECADES I'M NOT TOUCHING. OF
TRIMMING AND PRUNING AND
MANAGING. ARE FORCED IN
WILDLANDS. AND I THINK ABOUT THE
WILDLIFE. THAT HAS BEEN CREMATED
. BY THESE FIRES. AND THEIR
HABITAT LOSS FOREVER. IN THE
RESIDENTS WIPED OUT. THE VICTIMS
OF THAT PARADISE FIRE. THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WITH ONE
ELECTRICAL COMPANY. ARE TO BE
RECOMPENSED. BY REVENUE. FROM
THERE. THE OF THE UTILITIES. ARE
NOT GOING TO HAVE TO PAY FOR.
THAT'S HOW THEY DO ON WALL
STREET THAT WILL GOVERN. WHAT
DOES HOMEOWNERS GET FOR THE
HOMES. BUT THEY LOST. WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT SIX WELL EXEMPTION
FOR THINGS LIKE THIS. OFFER
SITES RESERVOIR. THAT WILL BRING
WATER. TO OUR CITIZENS. A
RESERVOIR THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD IN
OVER FIFTY YEARS IN THE STATE.
BUT WE CAN'T. GIVE A RESERVOIR
ANY EXEMPTIONS FROM SEQUEL AND
THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN STUDIED
FOR FIFTY YEARS. WE NEED TO
STUDY IT MORE. NO WE DON'T. SO
I'M NOT GOING TO VOTE NO TODAY
BUT I'M GONNA STAND ON THIS ONE
TOO. DOESN'T GET A LITTLE BIT
WARY. OF HYPOCRISY THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTER WINNER YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOT A PRESIDENT- APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TO HIM- THIS IS. AND WHATEVER
ONE'S VIEWS ABOUT THE STADIUM
SICKLE BILLS- THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE FOR
EXAMPLE SENIORS ACROSS THE
STREET SAFELY. ABOUT ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO BUY MORE
SAFELY THE BATTLE I'M PEOPLE WHO
TAKE A LIGHT RAIL OR THE BUS TO
GET TO WORK ON MORE QUICKLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU CENTER WIENER BUT
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS. AYE BATES NO BACKER OR
JUST BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTESE
DALLY. DODD AYE TORONTO AYE
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
GROVE. HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL. FOR
TODD I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA I LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MAN I
NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHOI BOGUE AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER I STERN.
NUMBER WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BACKER PORCHES BRADFORD
CABALLERO WHAT HAVING DOLLY.
GONZALEZ GROVE WESTERN I LIMÓN.
MELENDEZ NEWMAN NIELSEN STERN
NUMBER WELL. IS TWENTY FOUR
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ACTIONS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. WELL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY MAY NINETEENTH THIS
THURSDAY TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT
NINE AM. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED AND WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM HAVE A GREAT
REST OF THE DAY.